8月11本投稿中登録者90万人目指して
ますチャンネル登録よろしくです
知らないいらないいらないいらないいら
ないいらないいらないいらないいらないい
ないこのカード何枚もあるから
[音楽]
俺ももっとレアなカードを集めて人気者に
なりたいな
わかんねえよ
[音楽]
いらっしゃい
これくださいはい160円ね
当たった
[音楽]
それ本当の価値は100円だけど500円
で買ってあげるよえ500円もくれるの
ありがとう
やったー儲かったぞすいません買取査定お
願いしますミュウツーGXですねこちら
1万円の買い取りとなります
[音楽]
おい俺のこと騙したなカードの価値も
わからないキッズはポケカやらない方が
いいよ
[音楽]
できたぞ
[拍手]
[音楽]
これください160円です
よーし当たったぞー
みんな見てジャジャーン
[音楽]
昨日僕もお父様に買ってもらったんだ
めちゃんこすげー
すって何なの僕が持ってないのは
帰り切りザードンかな帰りきりザードン
あのカードショップに売ってたやつか
とにかくお金を稼いであのカードを買おう
[音楽]
ねえデッキ見せて
このカード本当の価値は10円だけど
100円で買ってあげるよありがとう
交換してあげるありがとう
[音楽]
はいじゃあ授業を始めます
こんにちは
[音楽]
おいしいです
[拍手]
[音楽]
もうこんな並んでるのか今更
占って無駄だぞ
諦めろ先着いじめリレーのカードあげます
か
[拍手]
こうなることは想定済みだったんだよ
これ買取お願いします
全部で10万円の買い取りとなります新作
パックあるだけください
[音楽]
準備
完了
よってらっしゃい見てらっしゃいお客様
本店もやれってカードショップだよ
[音楽]
くださいここに1億円あります残念だけど
リザードは今100億円に上がったんだよ
ね100億円
こうなったらもう
盗むしかない
[音楽]
お疲れさん動画に
変わるかしこまりました
[音楽]
分かったぞ
これで宇野に勝てる
[音楽]
ニュースの時間ですコケがバブルが終わり
を迎えました
カードの偽物が多く流通したことによる
詐欺被害の増加を受けてカードの価値が
急激に落ちています
これも
これは
また世界で一番高いポケットされる怪力
リザードンの価値も100億円から10円
になった模様です
[音楽]
嘘だろう
たくさんの人を騙して行動を見せて逃げた
[拍手]
[音楽]
それが欲しかったリザードンだかっこいい
ニュース
じゃないんだただの紙切れなんだよ
いいから
俺は何か
勘違いしてたのかもしれない
おもちゃって本来
楽しく遊ぶものなんだ
[音楽]
よしバトルだね
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしくチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル登録よろしく最初は
じゃんけんウルトラまたね